alright this is a
pepper panic saga level 223 walkthrough
tutorial
video and the play to the level and try
to complete it is in the
explain the decision they make it a go
if you play this one already you know
it's tough
and the hardest part is getting the
purple explosions
purple peppers don't fall off the board
as often as the green the blue
which makes it very difficult with a
small spaces
to get those to explore
there's gonna be some timers there's a
fixed number timers on this board so
there's
yes always tell a room at one time
they include the petrified wood so
yet six here so for more gonna drop
I look around the city with the worst
area is this one I guess is the worst
because
there's no purple occurs at all in a
minute get
covers the fall is hope that they will
be purple one or more so
you see that like to a felon them out to
more people
so now we can this now there's no more
that are gonna fall to remove or
them so all just the abandon the section
with her to return to grow the purple
as fast as and
unfortunately with here
takes a little bit of help to get though
missus this is really important to
explore this purple paper
here
alright so there goes war
that that's that's good the third out
with more even more
fantastic so no
there all the purple their separate what
we want to do is get ready for these
orders right away i'm looking to make
the team because it's going to remove
the thing that's going to bring in a
tire as you can see this time replace
the page but after that they're
and several others has exposed the
spring
and
started a reaction with the
we had a kind with couple moon
there because all the figures were the
ones that shared
really good job there
which is nice but these tire ago
blockers
game this paper the
your hair purple together in other areas
for food
will ship this forum get a little bit
bigger
if we can go through it again we'll see
it this morn
again like to make the team is going to
make a regular for peppermint
we should be all initial we need one
more
the purple the news here
between three greens as well
we're gonna lose whatever grocery and
we should yield
make the purple
hope that this is what we were there was
a little bit but this
is
you see as you can see like the its way
easier to create action with the other
colors
so alright to
down here we have 3
Perth three so this or make an explosion
in a bit able to finish up the
the green order a so
that's going to complete the level
you see like how important the purple is
hopefully
the because it really is easier to pick
up the other order that the
and you also see that is difficult to
describe
hey all the way to do it is his book the
purple peppers because they're just not
available
that readily so that you can you know do
it every single time
but this helps for you to understand how
to
beat level and hope your
you have any questions you leave a
comment you know
be sure to get back here like us on
Facebook
make sure you visit our site the share
our guys if you find them helpful so
that other people define
that's all we have will have more videos
soon
thanks